all right so Samus is clear and I'm just
gonna start working my way through these
one by one only care about the original
151 yeah I'm kind of the same way so as
part of that why not go with Pikachu
let's begin classic mode
with one of the most iconic Pokemon of
all time
Pikachu himself and since you got
unlimited continues basically I'm just
gonna crank the intensity up every time
let's try this again shall we look ash
you don't have to be changing constantly
whoa dude
I wonder if you do more damage to
squirtle where he's a water pokemon I
mean you should write if they want to
stay true to Pokemon lore they should
still so surreal seeing Sonic a Nintendo
game oh man do you remember that I can't
remember if I've talked about this poor
nah I think you were an eg em read or to
write electronic gaming monthly cuz they
actually did an April Fool's joke many
many years ago that was like Sonic's
coming to smash and it was just an April
Fool's joke and then years later what do
you know it actually happens totally
legit like what does this Pokemon doing
maybe that's the equivalent of the
Goldeen back on a smash brothers melee
the Goldeen that just flops around there
still remember that that one of the
all-time great April Fool's jokes cuz
back then you know before like the
Internet's big it's like wait what
the only clues you had where oh wait the
date on that says April 1st back then
people just didn't it didn't think the
way they do now about like now everybody
knows April 1st like ok everything I
read today on the internet it's gonna be
a joke
it's bigger game featuring Nintendo's
most iconic characters at Sonic not just
Sonic now now they've got of course they
added Solid Snake they've got a cloud
some final fantasy Ryu in Kim now or Ryu
I guess is the correct way from Street
Fighter and Kim oh and then did you see
the big announcement from The Game
Awards Chris tallien Joker from persona
5 I was about say persona 4 that is cute
like that games not even on the switch
that's impressive dude
that is so impressive I actually don't
even know who it's more impressive or is
it more impressive from Nintendo or more
impressive for Atlas
[Music]
she's pretty excited about it yeah like
that's that's a huge deal man
huge deal I don't think I've died yet
this run have my Lucario oh dude I
forgot Lucario's in this one too I mean
pretty much every every character that's
ever been in smash is in this version
come on it's not the move I wanted to do
but okay
so is this just the theme for the whole
my whole run with Pikachu is gonna be
all about fighting Pokemon everywhere oh
you dodged that it was nice
I don't like fighting down here but
[Music]
whoa whoa I don't remember this stage is
it about to like totally shift probably
so oh okay that's how you want to do it
we'll kario that works that works nice
play intensity up to 7.5 grid injure
yeah I guess it is a theme that makes
sense cuz when I was Samus we fought
Ridley and we fought fought Dark Samus I
see this stage so far so good I like
this
[Music]
dang peez stuff
oh he went for that Pokemon
Yipes dude
[Music]
well that was his
dude what hit him in midair oh my gosh
would we need the Nintendo online
subscription thing if we wanted to play
each other yeah yeah man it's only like
20 bucks for a year but I'm kind of on
the fence about it honestly my friend
who has this game as well he was saying
that online it's like just so awful
right now just in term I mean you know
how Nintendo has always been so weird oh
my gosh okay this guy's like he's not
playing around all right
the difficulty has ramped up within
center over here whoa okay settle down
take a Pokeball to the face relax dude
that move is awesome where he throws you
into the turnbuckle like a wrestler
[Music]
yeah we got to start taking him
seriously there we go
would we come back yeah so you need the
online subscription but I haven't heard
good things so far hopefully they
hopefully they improve it I heard that
they improved it a lot with Mario Tennis
as that game went on
now see right there if they want to stay
true to Kannan Pikachu should be able to
touch that electric area right there and
suffer no consequences
see if we can do better here than we did
with Samus
like why not I don't understand I guess
you have to hit the blocks to destroy it
and go back I'm not going back
it'll just proceed forward and complete
all right master Han crazy hand time
this is our second classic mode
playthrough oh wait no it's not never
mind
mu tou our second classic mode
playthrough here completed it already
with Samus now we're going through with
Pikachu oh nice Dodge
[Music]
oh nice does well time by him
later Pikachu dominates the Mewtwo wait
this is totally different man why didn't
I fight crazy in this time I need that
tomato whoa
[Music]
it's not the attack I thought he was
about to do right there
[Music]
come on give me another tomato come on
get back up there
nice Pikachu let's go whoa this is a new
attack I don't like it you chew so light
man yeah I don't oh there we go
that's the movie that I needed him to do
right there lots of damage there no no
that's another new move man you're still
seeing new moves from him bought him
twice all right music continue here I
[Music]
can't remember how was it that you've
got crazy hand in the old games cuz this
time when I got to the end
I had to fight Mewtwo and then just
regular old just master-hand came out oh
no
stay away from that thing there we go
all right classic mode number to
complete pickets you down see if we
unlocked another character I hope so
Kos yeah so Mewtwo and master Han on one
together maybe it's just different for
reach character eight point six that
time master hand has been defeated good
skip through all this
[Music]
congratulations 21 hits 5 defeated 21800
points all right give me all those
rewards let's go let's go be the rewards
fighter spirit the other thing I miss
Christian that they don't have this time
are the trophies I mean they're still
there still they're kind of in the form
of spirits oh yeah let's unlock shulk
here we can beat him this stage is weird
[Music]
no no no no that move that moves tricky
sometimes like if you use it the wrong
spot charge it up for too much you can
be taken out so it's risk reward so
right there and nailed him with it nakta
mom Shulk joins the battle I don't you
know how many characters there are in
total I know there's a ton I don't even
think I've half of them yet